you are at the right place if you want
to understand what the byte pair
encoding support organization algorithm
is
how to train it on how the tokenization
of a text is done with this algorithm
the bp algorithm was initially proposed
as a text compression algorithm
but it is also very well suited as a
tokenizer for your language models
the idea of vpe is to divide words
between sequence of two words units
which are units that appear frequently
in a reference corpus
which is the gothburgers we use to train
it
o is a bp tokenizer trend
first of all we have to get a copies of
text
we will not try not to art organizer on
this raw text but we will first
normalize it
then pre-organize it
as the print organization divides the
text to a list of words we can represent
a corpus in another way by gathering
together the same words and by
maintaining a contour here represented
in blue
to understand how the training works
we consider this third corpus composed
of the following words
again face
hugging ugh a girl etc
bb is an algorithm that starts with an
initial vocabulary and then increase it
to the desired size
to build the initial vocabulary we start
by separating each world of the corpus
into a list of elementary units that
compose them
here the characters
we list in our vocabulary all the
characters that appears
and that will constitute our initial
vocabulary
let's now see how to increase it
we return to our split corpus we will go
through the words one by one on count
all the occurrences of token pairs
the first pair is composed of the token
h and u
the second u and g
and we continue like this until we have
the complete list
once we hold the pears
on their frequency of appearance
we will choose the ones that appear the
most frequently
here it is a pair composed of the
letters hal and he
we note our first merging rule
and we add the new token to our
vocabulary
we can then apply this merging rule to
our splits you can see that we have
merged holes of pairs of tokens composed
of the tokens hal honey
and now we just have to reproduce the
same steps which with our new splits
we calculate the frequency of occurrence
of each pair of tokens
we select the pair with is frequency
we note it in our merge words
we add the new token to the vocabulary
and then we measure also pairs of token
composed of the token
li on a
in two of our splits
and we can repeat this operation until
we reach a desired vocabulary size
here we stopped when our vocabulary
reached 21 seconds
we can see now that the words of our
corpus are now divided into far fewer
tokens than had at the beginning of the
training
on that our algorithm has learned the
radicals ugh and learn and also the
verbal ending ing
now that we have learned our vocabulary
on merging words we can tokenize next
text new text
for example if we want to tokenize the
word eggs
first we will divide it into elementary
units so it begins a sequence of
characters
then we'll go through our match rules
until we have one we can apply
here we can merge later h and u
on here we can merge two tokens to get
the new token egg
when we get to the end of our merge
rules
the tokenization is finished
and that's it
i hope that now the bpo algorithm has no
more secret for you